now she's making some money so now she's
like looking great and I'm like how the
hell damage who the [ __ ] yeah that's
what it sounded like to that's true
she looks different take me outside take
me inside [ __ ]
[Music]
all right does everybody remember cash
me outside girl like she took all my
money that bastard why speak on it
butter mixtape her only fans God damn it
I'm embarrassed to say
would you what'd you find in there was
it good content yeah what kind of
contest you make is it woe Vicky it was
great content damn it oh I know is it is
it the woe Vicky is that the same one uh
no catch me out catch me outside how
about that that's a different that's a
different one yeah bad baby yes baby
baby with the H oh I bought her [ __ ]
song on Apple was it good yeah it's not
bad huh she added some bangers and I'm
not gonna lie I was like God damn why do
I like this song and then my room would
just be like yeah she's way better than
the other one the Vicky girl well Vicky
whoa Vicky because then she make music
too I get them too mixed up yeah but
what about her oh don't you talk [ __ ]
about my girl dude watch your mouth I
just didn't realize we had a real fan in
here and that's really cool I'm glad
that you can relate to this fan that's
all
so bad baby AKA Danielle
pascalitz peskowitz brigoli I don't know
that name alone will make me unfollow
follow that [ __ ] holy she recently gave
a speech at Oxford University
that's dope yeah she she's killing it
though dude that's that's exactly why
right like going well the thing is she
got a chance to talk about with all the
students said that were obviously also
fans how she ended up making 50 million
dollars on only fans this last year so
you're a businesswoman 50 see and Hughes
one of the only fans basically go viral
and then
take that leverage and then go and make
your money but think about how she went
so would you do that would I would you
go if I went viral would I create an
only fans and make 50 million dollars uh
no I have morals
I'll do it in a heartbeat I'm like I'll
show this [ __ ] thing off for a minute
50 million dollars I'll do it for
[ __ ] 50 000 right now
for if you give me five G's that's nice
if you guys give me five G's the things
I'll show right now dude is ridiculous
because dude before she even did the
only fans like she had like a pre-order
and people she made what like well no no
here's it okay here's the thing here's
the thing dude here's the thing you
don't know talk to a customer
here's the thing she was I think she was
turning like 21 and she was gonna like
or I think it was 18 or 21 I think it's
18. she was turning 18 so she started in
only fans at 18 so she can just be like
so without your pre-ordering and
everybody's free everybody's waiting for
her 18th birthday that was like the
whole marketing thing and everybody was
like oh my gosh it's turning 18
everybody was just going after that
that's crazy yeah dude I was not before
that that was years ago I didn't come in
until late until late in the game 18 and
a half because she was like still
looking kind of like uh beat up and
ready but when she got the implants
making some money so now she's like
looking great and I'm like how the hell
damage who the [ __ ] yeah that's what it
sounded like what happens
she looks different take me outside take
me inside [ __ ] how she look now
and then you know that's when I just
when they get money something changes
it's called makeup and surgery this is
her on Dr Phil uh if we all remember
trying to get this she was trying to she
was trying to catch hands with Dr Phil
outside yeah and Dr Phil typical white
guy you want to do what now this is our
this is her 2013 film showing on Dr Phil
which was her rise to fame on the very
very viral very popular cash me outside
I mean that was that was a huge thing
you know what I mean that was really
funny she wasn't 18 then no she was like
60 17 or something 16. that clip was
hilarious right she was like 15. um she
was trying to fight Dr Phil oh the the
episode title was called I want to give
up my car stealing or knife wielding
torquing 13 year old daughter who tried
to frame me for a crime that was the
name of that episode so 13. okay so like
going around going from that to only
fans is not much of a stretch you might
as well take advantage of it well yeah I
mean she's making 50 million on it
that's still that's still she also
stayed
relevantages yeah let's be honest she's
not gonna go to Harvard you know what I
mean yeah she's going to Oxford she's
yeah to speak apparently [ __ ] and I mean
to be able to even say that you launched
a music career with the help of like
Kodak Black and Lil yachty like that's
that's impressive pretty impressive I
Got No Songs with Lil yachty yeah did
she pay them to do that
I mean I think she teamed up with the
right team that helped her maximize
whatever she had yeah because for sure
what would you call what she had because
don't you wouldn't you say that that
attention attention yeah it's just
attention and she maximized her
attention don't you think that video of
her on Dr Phil is more damaging than
anything right like at that time like
for her to be able to take that and
leverage it to anything else to have a
50 million dollar business that's pretty
that's pretty I think I think I think
what it was it was they were making fun
of her
I've already hit rock bottom I might as
well do X Y and Z I think it was like
the perfect storm of what we saw what
what things that were going viral like
when Instagram was like making things
just go [ __ ] viral like anything so
she was right at the peak right when it
was happening that just stupid little
phrase and we were starting to take
little things that we find putting it on
I don't think she was conscious of it no
I know I'm saying I think she just fell
into it and it kind of just happened and
then she just fell into the next thing
and then that kind of just was the ball
that had the rolling effect of where
she's at now yeah like I don't think she
was sitting there in a room with the
writer's room like strategically no no
that okay okay but now now people are
doing that now people are doing that
whenever they go on anything you can
just tell if you notice anything on TV
you can tell like they're just using
little bytes so they can try to get
clipped and then go to like viral if it
sounds absurd but at that time you're
right it just happened like she just
naturally but that's what I'm saying it
was the effect of like we're taking
little things that were just like
blowing it up on the internet and she
didn't know how to handle that I
actually met her on a at a knoxberry
farm no no start with that yeah no where
did I meet her I met her at uh Six Flags
Six but before before you were her only
fans yes
because that would have been weird
when I got the picture when I got the
picture it would have been like oh by
the way um actually yeah I'm actually
paying for your own fans
that would have been a little weird when
you met her was she cool was she nice uh
she you could tell was like a young girl
which is the popularity like you just
tell she was like very like like just
she can tell people are watching her she
was just a Fame [ __ ] at that time you
can just tell like she'll do things on
purpose you ever like uh you ever like
see a spoiled kid and you just like
they're talking they're trying to be
cool you're like you're just trying to
be there yeah get that cool person you
can just tell us it's fake this is not
who you are that's what she was being
she was very that's why you subscribed
huh because God damn those those you
know those hips don't lie after a while
when you're 21 I'm like my goodness they
got you you grew up [ __ ]
how did you meet her at Six Flags you
know she's like it's because you know
what she reminded me she reminded me of
like your best friend's like sister who
grew up here like God damn the fact that
you kind of know her a little bit you're
like damn [ __ ] I've seen you for a
while I've been watching you yeah I've
been watching it that doesn't sound
creepy at all yeah I've been watching
you after 18. and then and then after
you left later that night you subscribed
to her only fans 100 no no no I remember
uh only fans happen dude I'm gonna tell
you right now it wouldn't happen give us
a timeline and a freaking it happened at
a drunk night
and I was just [ __ ] pissed off at the
club getting dissed all night and I said
man [ __ ] this
he left he left because he knows what
I'm talking about no I haven't done yeah
[ __ ] you look like you [ __ ] do
that all the time no and then you go on
Instagram and then she just popped up
and I'm like who's this [ __ ] batty
who huh and then I went for it and I
realized wait that's the catch me
outside what did I do
I waited two more months to unsubscribe
I hate myself but in the moment you're
just [ __ ] tunnel vision
yeah but um what did she say
catch me outside like I mean at the
speed I'm so curious is there a video
over here obviously the idea that like
you know she was able to even share
screenshots from her only fans showing
the gross revenue of 53 million dollars
done in a single year that's obviously
impressive on some level that is pretty
cool she was able to it was pretty crazy
and then like the prior month she had
teamed up with the edu Capital
Foundation to create a 1.7 million
dollar scholarship which will provide
postgraduate entrepreneurial grants and
full scholarships to students so she was
able to talk about that these are
write-offs you know that's crazy talking
about her partnership explaining that
she wanted to make a real difference to
Young Hustlers and yeah it's probably
right off but at least she's helping you
know yeah well she's helping somebody
yeah and at least and this you know
you're in that space where you
understand you got to do that you might
as well do it in this way it's just made
all those students be like man [ __ ]
College
I'ma pop my [ __ ]
bro it's a hard argument to go against
you know probably after graduation
they're like why did I even study in the
first place like why am I even here
they're realizing colleges do girls ever
like think about doing the only fans is
that like a thought now for sure why are
you looking at me I mean I thought you
were a girl I mean what's your pronouns
definitely 31.2 percent Asian hello
hello hello hello
that never keeps changing slightly bro
it just goes up
every time every time I come here your
Asian bars dude yeah I mean
31.3 yeah we know homies that have like
transitioned into it transitioned into
Asia oh sorry uh
you can do that I'm doing it right now
right in front of you you should try it
your Asian went up a little bit yeah top
creators on only fans six figures a
month no yeah
yeah I want to talk to them yeah dude
yeah Julia thinking about it
it's about this topic several times oh
okay got you hey what's your take it's
the first time I hear it so what is your
take
I'm too chicken to do it yeah is it
because of the family thing what if it's
just what if it's just eating if it's
just eating sure see like I think girls
can get away with a lot of that stuff I
don't think I don't think I guess I
would do a bikini I would start with
bikini bikini people do that on Twitch
yeah it started just to see what it's
you know the momentum
and then people are starting
they're gonna be like you know what you
can't start at bikini you gotta start at
like feet or some [ __ ] you know
everything's still fully clothed listen
here you bro he is such an easy cough
out like somebody's gonna spend x amount
of money on just feet photos like done
that's a big deal that's what I'm saying
it's such a huge deal I don't get feet
you have to find that demographic I
don't understand that's that's one of my
friends on Instagram yeah I mean uh only
fans it's just feet yeah she's been here
many times cat yeah she's killing it she
transitioned from podcasts and then she
was like it was like an ongoing joke
like hey may we do feet did a little bit
popped bro what are the photos but at
least from what I know from the from the
people that are successful on only fans
it's not just photos it's not it's not
just photos and videos what is it it's
it's these interactions and Niche things
that you get like messaging you also get
like um you get like uh like like she
does this game where she's all like uh
like rate my dick
yeah that's a thing for like or like um
they'll just send it [ __ ] photos of
their dicks and she can talk [ __ ] on it
but like just the interaction I I met
her I met a girl I could absolutely do
that I'll troll all day on people's
dicks right so I met a girl that
actually does that all right Julian I'll
do a collab on trolling on people's
dicks let's do it once in a while
you get what you ask for you're gonna be
[ __ ] just dreaming of dicks all night
too because all you do is just [ __ ]
swiping through dicks you know the
category will be Finn Dom Financial
domination oh kind of in some ways well
actually no no Financial domination is a
little different you basically tell
people send me this [ __ ] money right
now or is your little bit wait we're
gonna be good at that why does she sound
already skilled
um is there something we don't know I
feel like everything is already out
there so oh they're great I think
there's still I would be afraid to get
raided by these two because they'll be I
think they'll be honest I'm like that's
gross it looks disgusting like you know
what I mean like the girth is not girthy
enough you know what I mean I think
that's what guys want that want that no
I think they're like no no they're like
they're like they're great they
specifically want the girls to talk [ __ ]
and degrade their dicks yeah yeah dude
this should be my ex-girlfriends they
[ __ ]
and they did it for free yes dude
[Music]